une production du studio sfr bienvenue
au sans fil dans le podcast on parle de
ce qu'on veut que nos invités date seach
ph quant à moi de me plante
cette semaine on vous annonce un
partenariat officiel avec un semi design
qui sont des caisses de cellulaires des
caisses d'ordinateurs plein de trucs
comme ce super cool une compagnie du si
une compagne bausch qui deviennent le
partenaire officiel du sans-fil podcast
en fait fait que pour les prochains mois
on a un code promo pour vous qui va
rouler en permanence donc c'est le sans
filtre en un mot 20% de rabais sur
n'importe quelle commande de 15 me puis
aujourd'hui pour annoncer ce qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a fait un petit peu car
spécial hors série qu'il va sortir
aujourd'hui nous on en prend acte et
ceux où besson voulait encore être un
petit peu plus puis s'entretenir avec un
des deux membres fondateurs ou en fait
deux actionnaires 1 prise par ci aux
deux caisses me kiwi il quitte un coq
qu'on connaît depuis un bon bout de jeu
déjà commandité le sans filtre mais là
c'est une commandite encore plus encore
plus intégrée encore plus globale c'est
vraiment maintenant nos commencèrent
officiel fait qu'on va en parler encore
un partout qu'on espère content d'avoir
cette opportunité de collaborer avec une
aussi belle compagnie d'ici qui ont un
parcours vraiment vraiment inspiré y est
ce qu'on voulait se rencontrent et où
elle puis encore une fois vous
rappellerai que pour toute commande chez
kiss me disait le code promo sans filtre
pour 20% de rabais
puis après avoir dans l'histoire ou la
laissant de plomb les encourage
fake bon pas de casque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wells a lui même salut les gars tels
humaine feijo streda pas recommencer
mais non annoncent leur partenariat avec
kate smith y est partenaire officiel du
sans-fil podcast on est bien excité même
moins de choses pour toute l'équipe
pourrait peser un but qu'on consent jose
2 ph mais on a décidé d'aller de l'avant
puis je suis d'ailleurs de voir que le
site y est vêtu est en fait tu es dope
pour ceux qui nous écoutent
on a un code qui va rouler pendant toute
notre partenariat pour kiss me si vous
voulez vous procurer en fait les
meilleures caisses de téléphone
d'ordinateurs de les chargeurs sans fil
fait que en un cocktail sans filtre on
m'a reparlé on va reparler puis à lecce
que ça c'est quand même 20%
sauf si on ne fait pas de rapidement et
honnêtement c'est aussi groupe qui note
black friday il donc si j'étais vous
rien fait que tu nous parles un petit du
du commun graves de deux caisses mipi de
toi commencer n'est parce que quand
qu'on avait fait une collaboration
le coût de la dépense et je pense là si
tu avais tu avais une ligne qui disait
start études en un seul dans le sous-sol
de des nouveaux maison familiale pickton
explique moi surtout dans le fond de
talent et à l'ouest dallas l'école
images étudia québec et au haut du corps
en fait campus de lévis a pas grand
monde qui sait que ça existe ça c'est
bien que fait qu'ils aient jeté mon bac
en administration et entrepreneuriat toi
tu viens de la bauge à lévis pas trop
loin non mais aussi à partir de 17 ans
j'habite à québec qui j'ai mon père donc
jeté là aussi j'ai passé une fois puis
et puis c'est ce puits pendant mes
études en fait je reste à québec aussi
le fait qu'après cette lettre fait
étudier en allemagne plus après ce
qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce-qui cannes vient l'idée tout a
toujours été un gars de business de tue
toujours voulu je me gêne que les dates
en direction de tes études louis lemay
sa relative petite entre mario pee wee
clamant qu'ils aient le goût d'avoir une
entreprise amendé mais
maintenant moi ça pleut c'est un
concours de circonstance en fait tu es
mon compagnon gabriel on mettait des
amis d'enfance on est allé à l'école
primaire ensemble en hausse puis nos
chemins se sont séparés à partir de
seconds rôles du terré dans une haute
école même chose pour moi puis ben ali
plus tard plus du tout jeunes ont un peu
non pas vraiment ce qui est exact puis
dans le fond et je venais de finir
l'école et tu travailles à ce moment là
pour android qui s'appelle w esprits en
fait j'étais au développement des
affaires là bas puis mon père et lui
avait plusieurs projets en cours et j'ai
commencé à toucher au marketing pour un
développement immobilier qui faisait
puis c'est à ce moment-là à peu près en
2015 au coin de l'oktoberfest ma blonde
propose en fait qu'on allait prendre un
verre avec gable et sa copine parce que
les deux filles étaient super ami ok
c'est fou la vidéo
le seul moment peut changer lumbres de
deux ans fait qu'ils aient emprunté le
même si vos blonde vous connaissiez vous
aviez pas connecté non pas vraiment non
je pense qu'on se croise une tonne en et
festivals les genres schengen où elles
sont nées des trucs comme ça puis les
conversations cool mais sans plus pilon
s'assoient ensemble puis finalement
après une coupe de billard ont ils
commencé je pose la question de ce fait
quoi toi puis il a aussi travaillé en
fait à temps plein dans une autre
entreprise qui me dit il doit moins lui
étudié au hec montréal puis à la
dernière année de son bac il devait
mettre sur pied un plan d'affaires a
vraiment le projet des rased
puis quand il est fait la présentation à
son prof et à la classe le profit et 10
ports et c'est un colis docteur devra
aller plus loin avec ce puits ce qui
était cool pour lui c'est que son père à
gabes avait une entreprise embauche
aussi qu'ils quittaient dans la
transformation de plastique acrylique
je suis là que j'imagine que c'est le
projet qui a proposé je me gêne que
c'était l'embryon de kate mais je me dis
nous amenait aussi avec lui
en arrière la tête que son père faisait
de la transformation plastique l'
exemple si ce qu'ils avaient en tête
c'est qu'il savait qu'il y avait la
machinerie qui accumulait la pousse
heures dans un entrepôt qui courent en
beauce parce que l'entreprise ne sont
pas lavés mis sur pied un projet avec de
mémoire bell canada pour produire des
études loin dans le projet tombé à l'eau
mais l'entreprise avait déjà acheté tout
l'équipement pour la transformation fait
légal avec ce serait fou de ce fait le
lui proposa sont pas exacts je voudrais
racheter la machinerie
on va mener ce dans le sous-sol de son
chalet à saint rené de beauce de saint
georges
quatre heures quasiment de montréal
fille et puis dans le fond ils
commençaient à l'avenir et à produire
des études en dans son sous sol puis moi
c'est à ce moment là que j'étais arrivé
par la bande puis lui était déjà lui et
vend des housses et étuis y avait des
tueries site web ans
à ce moment là ils visaient
principalement du corporatif s'accuser
des étuis et au chlore de des
entreprises et qui lui sont ni deux
premières s'était développé des bornes
avec un ipad que les dessus qu'ils
allaient installer dans les universités
et des cégeps pour faire des études
costumes pour les étudiants son idée à
lui c'est dire comme c'est les gens au
collège aux états unis et si tu vois
stanford où tu vas réussir les points
portent des gens sont fiers d'y verser
quand tu payes 35000 par session tu vois
vraiment porté ses couleurs exactes puis
à montréal
c'est peut-être un peu moins pas au
québec en général c'était peut-être un
immense besoin de mettre des bornes avec
un ipad plus tu vois là dessus si tu
fais toi même ton dont le titre est la
exemple une fois une couple de fois par
année soit la procure de ton université
soit jetée lille sa chute en matériel
puis il ya une borne qui est semi qui
étaient là qui pouvait être soi-même
personnes hésitent on est dessus aux
couleurs de ton univers salles existent
et le mal est fait ouais c'est lui qui a
fait de ce
puis moi quand jean bart qui en fait
dans le projet il était au point de
mettre le site en ligne qui était un
site transactionnel gab je suis bonne
chance aux supporter qui se fait
canadien monte un un chopper faille de
toutes pièces puis moi de mon côté j'ai
dit marketing numérique
ça commence et c'est drôle de dire ça
mais en 2015-2016 instagram step a c'est
vraiment c'est ça qu'il sait ce qu'ils
payent même c'est qu'on dirait que
maintenant c'est que c'est tellement
rendu quotidien bon ordre que qu'on
oublie même qu'en 2015
enfin les influenceurs ça commençait le
fait que la pologne a rassemblé
t'explique tout ce qui pour quoi qu'il
cherchait un partenaire fait cherchez
pas c'est moi qui donne les nacelles
j'ai dis honnêtement j'aimerais sur
m'occuper du marketing du fait mon psy
je travaille au développement des
affaires ce fait que développer le
marché et commerces au détail c'est être
que qui m'intéressait aussi avec giteau
garde
on s'entend sur un 10 x puis j'ai dit si
dans un mois on a réussi à générer des
ventes en ligne je vais acheter 50 % de
la business avec toi puis on nous trouve
c'était pour ce n'était pas grand-chose
50% ce moment là le cndd pour ça il est
plus compliqué mais risqué à ce moment
là c'était quand même si ces acquis
joron on va être capable tout finalement
le mois plus tard ben on a réussi avant
mais quand même plusieurs étuis en ligne
et charlotte mademoiselle rendrait en
marquis qui nous a donné un gros coup de
pouce au début c'est l'entraîneur qui
est comme c'est la même personne qui a
travaillé avec vous dans le fond titre
d'influenceurs ou deux types de
partenaires les mettons ce qui était
cool avec andré on sait qui elle partait
en même temps que nous presque mmc année
leur prendrait un légiste qui écrit je
pense qu'on s'est donné un coup de
téléphone pige expliquer le projet
piazza et dégager le goût de vous vous
encourager ce fait que je vais prendre
un poste de style qu'on copie dans ce
temps là le monde était à vous
réactif amène à vous écrit dans c'est
moi qui ai cliqué tout y est elle a dit
cool parfums aux concours exact as tu y
est attendu alors des allèles j'ai pas
des fois ça hip-hop en ait fini avec un
maquillage golf est là se pose pas de
questions après si c'était tellement
gentil de sa part puis on est encore
aujourd'hui on travaille ensemble
occasionnellement sur différents trucs
mais son passé ça ça fait exploser bon
ben on y passait des genres kata boni a
comme plus de 1000 de gens qui est
exactement dans notre personne à cible
qui est dû principalement à 25 % de nos
ventes cd des femmes âgées entre 18 à 35
ans à peu près un fake des gens qui la
suivait avait un intérêt potentiel pour
qui ce même si ce fake c'est vraiment ce
qui aidait à lancer le tout c'était ça
qu'est ce que nous faisons en moi qui ai
trouvé fascinant le puits que j'essaie
d'appliquer dans notre business à nous
autres le pire depuis dans ma business
parallèle ces deux du le gommer les
gaultier parce que vraiment ce qu'elle
dit c'est que si tu atteins d'avoir trop
d'aller trop double dans les chiffres
tu veux dire non avant d'arriver le
titulaire est ce qu'à fait ségo puis
après ça on manage les chefs qui je
trouve quand même c'est quand même autre
frein pis je pense qu'il ya un moment
que tu lances l'entreprise c'est là
qu'il faut que tu fasses des initiatives
qui étudia éthiques quoique j'ai à
perdre pour résister le pire qui pouvait
m'arriver avec candrian scam disent non
ouais ouais j'ai fait de la même chose
et anthony van drame qui partaient
pêcher fils 2016 jeudi à clichy protéger
dit j'aimerais cependant anthony puis on
trouve
et s'ils commettent hambourg à montréal
puis on va travailler ensemble puis nous
sommes en théorie pendant comme c'est de
commencer à enrichir du monde qui
t'intéresse que genre authentiquement si
c'est vraiment ce qui a aidé à faire des
beaux moves pis maintenant on est rendus
près 24 26 personnes qui travaillent
chez kiss me fais toi dans le fond le
jeu et garder la chronologie parce que
je trouve ça vraiment intéressant puis
super passionnant que sur ça vous
intéresserait aussi le manque nous
écoutent qu'un fait que l'auto tu donnes
ton temps un mois pendant le mois tu
rejoins rien puis le sable ou à bloquer
le virus tel deal achète 50 % de la
business puisqu'elle ont été ensuite les
étapes là vous êtes 2 vous n'avez pas
d'employés vous faites tout fait
l'expédition vous vous je roulais à peu
près combien de dekese par par jour par
semaine à ce moment là au début c'était
pas grand chose le pays via be fine
c'est sans son travail à ceinture parce
que là vous avez encore travail fo terme
dans les entreprises
autre fait qui finissait travail et y
aller à son chalet il ya les produire et
une coupe de kay si je peux recommencer
puis ça a duré à peu près un an je te
dirais qu'on est et nous deux
vous étiez juste 2 avec une job à temps
plein pendant un an
exact moi je me fais des allers-retours
québec saint georges et ma mère habite
encore en beauce fait que je peux aller
dormir au moins de chez elle puis on a
maintenu ce rythme jusqu'à temps qu'ils
emmenaient crime gabriel et produira
tout les soirs fait sa peau était du
jour au lendemain ça a été très
progressif comme croissant que vous
aurez jusqu'au jour que je t'aime en
ballon on avait besoin d'autres
personnes soit constant engager des
années graphique pour nous aider qu'ils
désignent de gueule
cependant pour des femmes c'était le
premier mot c'était d'engager des
anneaux graphique qui allait permettre
décrit le contenu quelques examens puis
l'étape numéro 2 ça a été d'engager
quelqu'un pour la production au début
c'était vous autres qui choisit les
dessins ouais c'était bien petit ce qui
sortait ses skis et photoshop piste est
incroyable et chic pour les photos de
mon iphone 6 puis on mettait ça sur
instagram fille ça a été très très
basique le com
mais là c'est pareil merci aux gens fous
afin que les gens pouvaient tripes et là
dessus mais je pense que c'était des
budgets commun c'est aussi et si oui il
y avait pas de coupes de braine au
québec qui vendait en ligne mais est-ce
que les gens n'étaient pas encore
habitués puis avait pas de bottes
balises c'est arrivé pas sur un site qui
utilise chaque fois notre site était
correct mais après si c'était les médias
sociaux qui le prochain
mais quand même rendu l'an 2015 il n'y
avait pas beaucoup d'entreprises qui
avait dès qu'ils avaient des contenus
médias sociaux intéressants en fait ça
se fait dessus avoir décaissé il étudie
d'autres caisses de téléphone un peu
funky avec design le fond nous c'est
aujourd'hui le quai telus un peu
ben c'est ça
notre compétition et un spécial dans le
sens qu'il y ait toutes les étuis genre
d'asie supporter chypre et il faut payer
saint pierre d'achoppement tels sont les
constats même pas comme la compétition
parce que ça je serais rien à voir avec
nos produits mais dans le style que nous
au vin il y en avait un gros aux états
unis qui est encore le plus gros
compétiteur s'appelle le cas stéphane
l'entreprise des ailes et puis où
existait déjà dans le fond je dirais que
c'était comme le seul qu'on connaissait
qui faisait des trucs ciment à nous mais
reste qu i télé québec
c'est dur d'en sortir une fois que tu
t'es parti au québec mais reste que les
premières années les gens sont tellement
gentils mauricia courrégé de commerce et
401 millions le bécut x 1001 mais est ce
que le sentiment d' encourager
l'entreprise québec citq au qui tient
vraiment à carreaux des québécois donc
qui sait sa belle tape dans douze dents
dans la dans la recherche développement
du kaist parce que moi aussi de loin les
caisses le meilleur casque que j'ai eue
de celle je sais pas combien de fois
j'ai frappé mon ciel sans que ça pète
si tu ça tue le qu'est-ce que j'ai
énormément il a laissé tout ya toujours
et esquisse le nom du camp des loges les
cas j'ai commencé et jeta les vitriers
de coupe ça se faisait
puis j'ai pris un étui dans mes mains
puis je les justes puis un peu qipao
fille avait expliqué qu'ils aillent
habiter la machine c'est la machine de
base qui avait pour faire les caisses
avec des machines étaient là même
c'était le produit c'était vraiment la
composante de l'étui en tant que tel
pile et je regarde bien vite je peux pas
vendre ces émeutes je veux pas mentir au
monde gérait ses bons fait finalement
gap s'est retournée bord on est allé
chercher différents types de
fournisseurs puis on en a trouvé un qui
essaient eux avec quiconque on travaille
encore aujourd'hui de fait à peu près 5
1 puis une entreprise du duke est fait
que nous on importe la matière première
qui le plastique des polycarbonates
vecsys pas flexible puis c'est un
excellent têtu et puis maintenant sont
rendus est 100% recyclable aussi
tout genre de gars essentielle nous
échappe toujours mon cell j'essaie
toujours toujours toujours comme les
caisses qui est ce mystère du moins
brise et on se met même ou si j'ai déjà
la bêtise nb d'un spatiale mais ouais
ouais vraiment j je les chapes
régulièrement la presse quotidienne tous
les faux raccords touboul parfait c'est
vraiment la bombe puis est ce que la
qualité du produit j'imagine que ça a
été un facteur qui vous a permis de vous
distancer des genres de la crap qui se
vend au d'exemple 150 visite un site web
dans vi qui va taper a laissé six
thibodeau et les gens l'achètent deux
premiers coups parce qu'il trouve le
design c'est mais qui l'arraché rivas de
tranchées de la qualité et la lépi ne
note pas qui jean toute l'expérience
client quand je suis tombé dessus et
quand même unique aussi à bien avec un
roquette
c'est quoi cette idée là qui a eu l'idée
mettre en quête de leroy 4 ceux qui vous
écoutent les petits bonbons l'es1 qui se
déroule depuis que je m'en suis même
puce
mais quand c'était gab qui avait cédé le
hameau je trouve ça je trouve ça
tellement hot comme idée moi amené
j'avais commandé des boxeurs chez emi en
2010 qui qui font un service de
souscription
tu peux aussi d'en commander des packs
de six de 10 puis je commande un pack de
10 10 quand même dispendieux le sait pas
des spas des boxeurs cheap et que je
commente serge camatchy c'est quand même
cher mais en même temps c'est que je le
reçois puis dans la boîte
j'avais une casquette une snab bac avec
la palette move le
noir la palette mots marc emig en dise
bras des genres de l'esti de qualité oye
plage et fait des traitements le prix
que je paye et je vais leur payer la
seconde parce que j'ai besoin d'un
nouveau boxer ça me dérangerait même pas
juste à cause de tirs dans l'expérience
client c'est incroyable autant en ligne
que hors ligne mais les deux faut que ça
soit cohérent et nous on est une
personne à temps plein qui s'occupe de
juste servi sa clientèle pitt et nous
étions rendus garanti 1 an on veut
vraiment que la personnel à reviennent
puisqu'elle a une expérience qui unit
ouais parce que c'est pas très justement
vous êtes un peu en fait votre produit
c'est un peu le
le défaut en guise business pleine nuit
je dirais vote a fait trois ans que je
vois pas revenir
sauf que est emmené que je les aime
tellement la seconde que je veux trouver
qu'une graphique dessus puis que vous
avez un nouveau design
je vous le commandez parce que parce que
c'est de la bombe et je te recommande et
parce qu'ils calent souilhe fini où il
est usé je l'a commandé par c'est de la
bombe
exact pourquoi cette chronologie l'état
d'engager un goût pour la production
engagée prévoyez à temps plein et à
étayer ma maman ah ouais ça a donné
demain mais je revenais je t'aime un
dormir chez elle puis leur mendicité en
tout match piqué je faisais bon il faut
qu'on aille acheter qu'un pilote
espagnol serait intéressé par ce jeune
artiste quand même travail que ta mère
et ton pac ne fait qu et finalement on a
jasé puis on s'est juste dit que ça
serait la meilleure chose qui tu peux
pas plus trop ce ticket ben non surtaxé
celle qui fait qu'il faisait la grimace
chine mais qu'est ce que t'es qui toi et
puis avoir vu des vertes et des pas
mûres le régent inondations dans le sol
challéat m'appelle les ordis sont pleins
d'eau genre
tellement d'histoires avec sophie à
l'essence est notre plus vieil employé à
ce jour à travers faisait avant de
rentrer chez vous à travailler en
communication chez canam manac ischia
grosses entreprises en beauce
ouais puis je vais je travaillais pour
toi je travaille et que monfils ou moins
exacts puis elle a cité deux parties à
travailler plus chez canam qui est parti
ils sont sa propre entreprise qui
s'appelait histoire de plumes s'était
envolée de colombes pour pourvoir les
mariages des mariages et c'était une
scène son modèle la pomme et ça il
prenait pas son temps à temps plein mais
tant qu'elle voulait les colons mais ce
qui revient ouais ok ses partenaires
principaux jamais depuis quelq l idée qu
un seul fait que good faith notamment
travaillé
l'équipe s'agrandit c'est quoi les l'on
mette en étant fashion en 2010 si tu ne
tombes c'est que les gros les gros
partenariats fait ou est ce que tu as vu
vraiment genre où est ce que tu as fait
à queneau social est un bon filon
viennent on vient prendre un autre
marche des grosses têtes mettons se
posait vous avez sûrement pas nier à
amman et une usine ou un local à louer
quelque chose mais c'est adéquat les
grosses étapes de l'avancement la
croissance parce qu'il est effectivement
vous êtes plus 27 dans le seul non non
non si c'est exact mais changer deux
fois de leucan ce fait qui est chemin
2007 en étant dans un local commercial
qui étaient quittés pas très gros mais
reste que c'était pour nous à ce moment
là puis dans une seule et oui c'était
fou mais prétendre à ta question de mais
si nous le ski était notre cause dans
machine ça a été tout ce qui est
influent sur web fait au début et genre
elisabeth riou qu'en cas des buts et on
ne travaille avec elle pendant le butin
une fille comme sarah couture aussi on
en viendrait des caisses avec eux dans
ce qui ce qui ce qui nous différencie
c'est qu'on fait beaucoup d dessus qui
sont personnalisées pour un artiste ou
pour prôner france heures puis on lui
lance en collaboration avec eux un fake
je dirais qu'on est on est une coupe
debout non comme ce petit sinon je
dirais que notre passage à lille du
dragon c'est leur demander si c'est une
institutrice
c'est fou hein ajouté ce qui s'était
passé comme des terralies dragon mask
est il foutu c'est fait aucun des eaux
personnes s'étaient l'avouer mais c'est
une claque dans face quand même parce
que on y allait pour la visite et
maintenant ils n'avaient pas besoin de
financement mais risqué de tout un petit
ego la tente pourtant de trois zones ont
été vus finalement juste des noms
clinquants c'était quoi les raisons
c'était du sud c'est parce que des fois
disent non parce qu'il dirige le temps
que vous n'avez pas besoin de nous
autres pays oui et non dans ce sens qui
est allé cellule est une mode ça va
passer mais leur point c'était les
jeunes s'associeront pas un brin de
caisse décès de leur genre l'ordi là il
se disait qu'il y avait un trou de
compétition deux reines avec ce passé
sexy c'est l'exemple
c'était stainier heureux parce que côté
compétition les dragons à cette époque
là c'était caroline néron dans les
bijoux compétitif très avancé et henson
de franck hanoh qui fait que je trouvais
ça un peu absurde qui nous dit ça mais
en même temps ça a été tellement
formateur si vous avez la visibilité est
nulle
puis c'est à partir de ce moment là pour
que je vous dirais que les lits - une
vente nous appelez nous écrivait pour
vendre du 15 mai que notre gros maman
pour nous ça a été de rentrer dans tous
les sens menzeh au canada puis ça a été
la sienne
un peu plus folles qui est précieux
c'est moi pour développement les
affaires c'était beaucoup plus facile
d'aller close et j'aurais b telus et
vidéotron d'être exact c'est une belle
étape
le site dirait que le retail ça se
trouve à être quel pourcentage de votre
business versus les ventes en ligne
je dirais que c'est 25% à peu près fait
qu'encore un massivement vente en ligne
puis on veut garder le focus la basculer
l'image d'un son vrai nom louis henri
gt2 on contrôler l'expérience client de
a à z fait qu'il est le web pour nous
c'est vraiment le con qu'on se concentre
c'est vraiment mais il ya une question
qui m'est venue faut que fo qui me
reviennent parce que est intéressant
vous flatter dans le sens du poil
ouais si ce n'est pas une question mais
c'est le disait que la critique des
dragons était dit je peux pas d'associer
dans mon entourage puissent même pas
parce que parce qu'on a collaboré
ensemble sur le sans fil d'installer ma
famille écouter même pas sans filtre
mais ça c'est ma famille sont arrivés
sur le tard mais le sans fil c'est la
personne ne l'écouté plus ma soeur est
tombé dedans tu es à ferrara qui gérait
écoute tout au complet capable de
t'entendre parler finalement millions
juste que ma soeur a commencé à faire à
broder pas d'abri côté à faire du tricot
plat comme grand secteur sans fil plus
adhérent du genre à la tout écouter le
jusqu'à comme l'épisode genre 60 les
faits qui restent encore 60 épisodes à
reculons ça va pas en s'améliorant ces
votants soit nommé mais ouais tout mon
entourage ce qui ce mime
je leur ai pas parlé de tuer c'est juste
que pendant puis on peut parler de ton
un peu pas mal la pandémie avec le
mouvement acheter local vous avez fait
une initiative de tondre de pub dab sur
facebook puis sur les réseaux sociaux de
comè voici une compagnie locale qui vend
des caisses puis moi c'est là que tout
le monde dans ma famille
acheter un casque et semi ma mère avait
besoin d'un ken son ordi mais sort avait
besoin de 15
puis ils sont allés de sucre premier ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé par un
confinement vos autres parce que je sais
que ça a été un gros boum le level up
complet le 1er confinement ou est-ce
qu'on avait vraiment l'espèce
d'effervescence
mais je les ai vécus avec vega d'impôt
plate dans le temps plein en puis ça a
explosé les ventes lotis puisque le
monde capote est ce le fait que c'était
fait aussi c'est un moment tellement
incertains que je trouve que on sortait
ça s'est passé en mars 2020 puis il ya
eu trois semaines combattre et non ce
débat comme n'importe qui en fait qu'il
soit que tu ailles est une business
support c'était un moment d'incertitude
est incroyable puis on se dit qu'est ce
qui va se passer on est en train de
faire des scénarios comme est si ça va
mal on fait ce saut ça on n'a même pas
pensé que ça pouvait vraiment bien
marrer ouais
puis le boom vous obtiendrez des
fenêtres apporte de personnes et on
était déjà dans ses plans de meta
acheter finalement danse jamais jamais
dans senteurs c'est effectivement peu de
contraintes ses flancs c'est que on
tombe sans emploi me relâche était kill
pourrait si françois legault qu'il
cartonnait tout le temps ni disait comme
acheter de casse important depuis le
boom ces partis puis les gens qui on
n'avait pas grand chose à voir le chez
nous et dont ils se sont mis un magazine
un petit toutes mes amis en commun donc
toute vie quand même chose que genre le
monde prenne la parole leur argent ou
georges comprennent police mais c'est
aussi un seul mot en français un
testament et est même tout genre preuve
que les gens vous font vraiment et
veulent vraiment vous encourager s'ils
prennent leur argent dumain durement
acquise dans un moment d'incertitude
financière pour acheter vos produits
c'est la preuve qu'il triple sont le
vécu tu es actuellement je dirais
peut-être 50 % nos ventes sont au québec
1 30 % au canada anglais puis le même
mouvement au situés au canada anglais
dont in the brain au québec comme étant
une entreprise québécoise mais au canada
on dit on est trop de risques en
addition c'est le mauvais et paraît
duster côté le reste les gens étaient
confinés par tous dans sa planète s'y
fait qu'elle ment s'y sont mis à acheter
en ligne comme jamais c'est surtout qui
est des gens comme nos parents n'étant
qui avait pas le réflexe d'acheter en
ligne
on est allé chercher un pourcentage de
gens qui avaient jamais acheté 10 me de
revenus en ligne en chine l'an puis ce
je pense ça a été un bond en avant au
moins de 5 kg en termes de huy
comportementaux leur comportement
d'achat en ligne c'était juste fou me
lafforgue et tu réalises puis je pense
qu'ils aient beaucoup de monde qu'ils
ont réalisé on parlait du retail tantôt
démarche différente
l'achat en ligne si ton expérience est
bonne c'est ton expérience client et
bonn puis ça fait pas trop chier sur soi
ce que tout commander m'attends à ce que
j'imagine qu'au début du iie comme si tu
pouvais commandé quelque chose hors ceux
votés ton histoire de la chemise que de
commandes est humaine qui arrive juste
pas piquer comme toi qui avais il y
avait la méfiance déjà etrm et à 4 des
crédits sur internet sur le terrain mais
une fois qu'ils passent par dessus
mettons que l'expérience client et bonne
culture chose que tu veux puis ans dans
un temps raisonnable
ben en tant que consommateur ttt contin
d'acheter au même prix en ligne puis de
donner une meilleure marge aux clients
que de donner une marge à wal mart ou à
la loterie telle histoire qui prend 40 %
ton truc latino avec 6 ou le
supplémentaires compte qu'on fait en
ligne
c'est à peu près ça c'est la deuxième
année le congrès fait un virage plus éco
responsables parlant
fake cette marge le supplément pas nous
a aidés à tout changer notre packaging
on est rendu avec du packaging kyiv qui
fait de carton recyclé source et festif
et s'est dit sûr c'est festif si vous
voyez sur son enveloppe ça veut dire que
l'élise à bhl qui ont été utilisés pour
ce ont été replantés par la suite
fake en plus le carton qu'on utilisait
et biodégradable puis on a décidé aussi
s'associe avec une cause qui s'appelle
écologique est une fondation qui
magnifique pourrait hermé décidé de
planter des arbres en 2020 mais on ne
plante ayons blanc planté cas l'an 2000
on a planté finalement 63 minutes
ces examens table avec cette année on
vise 1 100 milles ont peut-être même
quand deux ans votre capable d'atteindre
les 200 m puis et que légiste qui coule
c'est contrairement dans le plusieurs
formations qui fonctionne la plantation
d'arbres c'est quand même 10 pendu
honnêtement qui eux ils ont le modèle de
stand up de theix et genre c'est fou le
dialogue sur ton compte de l'écologie le
peak oil non davantage réel ou insultant
ta propre fort et gentil avec nous notre
forêt qu'ils me le disent haut et très
haut et il paraît divisée dans le monde
d'anton rue de la façon qui cible ou
vont être les plantations ce en fonction
des besoins des besoins locaux
pis ou est ce que la pollution et est
supérieur fait qu'il se concentre
beaucoup sur les pays en afrique qu'on
implante énormément d'armes madagascar
par exemple puis e place d'envoyer leurs
équipes de planteurs d'arbres écologie
parce que tu envoies du monde en avion
pour les planter des arbres c'est ce
fait qui est finalement et engagent des
personnes
le câble fait qu'en plus de planter des
arbres et on encourage les économies
le cal puis des gens qui sont dans le
besoin ainsi se prononcer ce pas
important
puis on ça se sait que beaucoup de
causes aussi comme l'on ne vend mode
jonças sets secs et bo baudouin pour une
initiative pour la pride qui fait qu'on
fait on fait différente et celui qui
fait avec les couleurs de l'arc en ciel
travaillent justement qu'il cendres qui
quitte avec vous en faites
car l'art dit du shell et jesse nadeau
aussi on est on a plein de personnes
puis est partie des fonds qui des
profits en fait qui vont être remis à un
organisme sait de quoi qu'on fait tout
au long de l'année puis nous c'est une
des façons de se lever le matin puis on
se dit alors c'est quoi le but fort quoi
qu'on vend notamment des peu ce qu'on
dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme
différence en tant qu'entreprise pillon
on va lancer sous peu
prochaines initiatives qu'ils
s'appellent de rubi ball qui est notre
nouveau slogan donc oser être audacieux
ok nous ment on veut suivre nos propres
conseils se fait qu'on va mettre sur
pied différents types d'initiatives fait
que qui adresser dans les prochains mois
ça va commencer à sortir
c'est vraiment cool man c'est vraiment
retourné classement comptant même de
s'associer aux autres pour ses smart
pour le sans-fil je pense que ces deux
visions qui se rejoint le team dans
l'esprit dans la dent
les gens qui participent fait que je me
pose la question t on
honnêtement on a essayé beaucoup en ce
moment de se concentrer sur l'extérieur
du québec pour parce qu'on aime paul qui
avait avec lui mais plus parce qu'on
veut on veut grandir puis quand qu'on se
pose la question avec qik on veut
travailler parce que c'est de quoi as-tu
moi je teins jeu le plus gros fan de
poker je vous écoute à toutes les
semaines je me les ont pas de casse
progresser tendu un problème le jeu mais
risqué quand qu'on discutait depuis j'ai
parlé de vous et vous avez une vol qui
est incroyable les invités que vous avez
ces deux-là top qualité les sujets que
vous abordez ils sont vraiment
intéressants ce fait je trouvais que
c'était naturel de travailler avec vous
là dessus et puis on est tout autant
motivé les boyz je pense que c'est
vraiment fine à vue et génère question
de parler de l'international avez-vous
des vous cherchez des influences aussi
américain international va de près
autour de 300 collaboration par mois
ich avec du monde à travers la planète
on m'a dit mais je vous dirais c'est au
québec qu'on doit en faire une
cinquantaine par mois puis la balance et
toutes les autres provinces au canada
etats unis europe qui sait ce qu'il fait
le web c'est qu'ils en aient pas défense
et c'est incroyable c'est au-dessus
poursuivre un lieu qui fait de la course
en australie si gate part d'un produit
ça t'intéresse pas c'est parfait mais
vous pouvez jeter n'importe où dans le
monde ouais ouais c'est qu'il est
maintenant la personne la plus film
c'est qu'il sait qu'il a plus
performants les bonnes questions pour
vous
si les passants qui s'éteint tout je
pense que là c'est relatif à chaque
personne puis toute mon équipe j'ai une
équipe qui est incroyable puis chacun on
trippe sur des trucs en particulier si
moi j'ai eu la chance de travailler
quand un artiste qui s'appelle ricardo
carvalho qui t'ont artistes que je tripe
solides puis finalement le guerrier a
accepté de faire une colle avec nous
et justement qui avait une qui n'est
cordeau marque était une nuit il a voulu
travaille plus au bout de 1 pour
justement le projet de la praille
chaque personne peut trouver son compte
puis c'est de but qu'on s'amuse avec
c'est ça qui est hôte avait en fait
c'est que vous travaillez aussi que deux
mondes sont pas nécessairement connus
mais qui sont quand même mis chez mais
qui ont un esthétique vraiment au fait
que ça fait des produits qui sont
vraiment ces méthodes est quelqu'un qui
pourrait être un gamer un micro
influenceurs mais qu'un esthétique
fucking des vins plus la colère mais
quand décliner shops et nous le but de
développer des relations qui sont 100%
lui-même avec tout ce monde si je trouve
qu'il boucle brain qui qui font des
influenceurs massivement mais et aucune
naissance dans cette relation l'est un
numéro pense que nous c'est détendu 10
trucs à long terme qu'on veut forte il
ya des gens que ça fait six ans qu'on
travaille avec eux faye s'est rendu des
relations que ce moment d'amitié n'ont
ni veulent le faire juste parce qu ils
trippent travail et que nous si vous
aviez travaillé qui est avec kim gingras
je trouve vraiment que c'était vraiment
un bon fit parce que t es connu est en
scène allemand pour la danse le tpiy
mais québécoises actives on dirait que
ces groupes vraiment l'ambassadrice
parfaite parce que demander n'importe où
qui a suivi mais comme mais représente
aussi le québec le cefic entre que c'est
comme si ses parents en phase avec les
altimètres découle justement avait voulu
donner 100% du cinu d'enfants comme un
con vous avez un partage la confiance
n'est un étui vraiment custom pour une
personne on la vend en ligne puis une
pourcentage un pourcentage des ventes
qui est remis à un artiste ou alain
françon puis elle a voulu donner 100% à
écologie fait pour chaque et dessus on
plantait 10 armes c
est ce comme marina bastarache on a fait
une collab avait pu l on est étonné de
ces déchets un des chiens pis les fonds
étaient réunis à la haye spécifiques
il ya plein de choses domaine qui est il
l'on en parle j'ai plein de noms qui me
pape en tête remet ça mais on se
contenterait chant soul d'abord gagner
le respect de ces gens là depuis lors
leur confiance aussi à travailler que
nous où est ce qu'on peut voir les
qu'est ce que vous faisiez en 2015 soit
pigalle chez qui ce minuscule -
qu'est-ce que vous avez toutes vos
questions à ce que vous dites mais
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà créés n'ont
été une salle qui le musée des cas ici
mais on est en train de déménager long
deux de ses percussions être un peu
comme 7000 pieds carrés
maintenant que chez ça représente quand
on sait que nous ont produite les tuant
bosse fait qu'il faut la classe pauvre
et les machines qu'on utilise ça prend
ça proprement le place puis le bain
pandémie un fait qu'on a eu on est passé
je pense 18 à 26 personnes fidèles des
compliments arrive on va retourner au
bureau ce fait que l'on est comme ça qu
on manque de place solide fait que l'on
va grosso mais c'est dans les plans de
d'encadrer des étuis et qui ont été pas
des d'état banc d'or ou des mégots fait
au genre plus bas oui oui ta g ou
boulevard des lieux des impôts très bon
et merci infiniment même c'est vraiment
une super collaboration on est vraiment
contents encore une fois ceux qui nous
écoutent code promo sans filtre pour 20%
de rabais sur tous les produits qui est
semi exactement yassir fait que merci
mais non merci à vous les yeux cheveux
la maxi depuis merci à tous pour les
coteaux seiller merci d'avoir écouté ce
podcast jusqu'à la fin j'espère que vous
avez apprécié la conversation ça prouve
que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe
hier sur p tu es a non seulement on met
tous les podcasts en ligne au moment où
est ce qu on les tourne donc on a
beaucoup de semaine d'avant sur le
pétrole mais on fait aussi des encore
moins de filtres qui sont exclusifs au
monde pète urnes puisque on parle
d'hommes que l'émoi de la conversation
qu'ont bien d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu
plus en profondeur dans certains sujets
qu'on voulait aborder ou qu'on abordait
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page culturelle et le lien vers ce havre
dans la description du podcast qui
remercie encore une fois de nous avons
écouté jusqu'à la fin